to create the spectacular clothes
required for the character of Kit The
Producers called upon Academy
award-winning designer Edith
Head not everyone knows that clothes are
screen tested as carefully as performers
these are wardrobe tests never intended
for public viewing the comments are by
Miss headed herself here's Lana Turner
the beautiful star of love has many
faces the spoiled beautiful woman with
all the money in the world the woman who
makes her own rules the woman who lives
for love and glamour this incidentally
is a look we used right through the
picture the the toga the rather loose
Greek look of clothes